[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être là je vais
ce soir vous raconter une histoire de
développement une histoire d'engagement
une histoire de passion l'histoire de
deux amis un paysan burkinabè est un
maçon français qui a une vingtaine
d'années ont imaginé qu'il pouvait être
transformé l'habitat en afrique ont
commencé à le faire en vélo dans les
brousses burkinabè et cette année avec
leurs organisations ont remporté le prix
mondial de l'habitat d' décerné par
l'onu
ce maçon français pour qu'ils avaient
aussi par mariage c'est moi thomas
granier
je viens d'un milieu plutôt aisé mais
contrairement à ceux qui sont passés
avant j'ai pas brillé à l'école j'étais
pas vraiment assidus et vraiment pas
fait pour ça et très tôt je me suis
tourné vers les métiers du bâtiment
principalement la restauration du bâti
ancien et les matériaux nobles la pierre
le bois
j'ai trouvé là à gérer mon énergie et à
peut-être dépenser un peu ma créativité
pendant plusieurs décennies
parallèlement à ce plaisir de la
construction j'avais aussi une passion
pour les voyages et quand je dis voyage
était plus les gens que les paysages
pourrait pas que je slame non plus
et finir au chômage
j'ai eu la chance de voyager tôt les
etats unis l'europe l'inde le maroc où
je passerai plusieurs années et
finalement au milieu des années 80 c'est
le burkina qui m'accueille avec sa
prodigieuse chaleur humaine au burkina
je rencontre un sacré bonhomme konaté
baum avait la caste des forgerons un
sculpteur un créateur vous m'avez n'est
pas seulement un créateur il est aussi
l'ami des créateurs et un boromo sa
ville d'adoption
à mi distance entre ouaga et bobo dans
les années 90 il crée le piia mais park
international des arts modernes et
traditionnels ou une fois par an par ce
qu'il appelle un symposium
il invite des artistes africains et
européens à s'asseoir pendant quelques
semaines pour créer côte à côte
je me passionne et je suis cette
aventure et en 98 je propose à baulmes
avait de participer moi-même au
symposium de cette année là en y
apportant ou en tentant d'y retrouver
plutôt la voûte nubienne la voûte
nubienne qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
très ancien concept technique ça à plus
de 3500 ans ça vient d'eux du haut nil
l'egypte du sud nord du soudan
les nubiens aujourd'hui son d'un peuple
ne sont plus un pays est cette technique
permet de construire des structures
voûté briques de terre crue mortier de
terre crue son coffrage sans rien qui
soutient cette voûte qui avancent
pendant louvre âge et en technicien du
bâtiment je m'intéressais à comprendre
comment est ce que c'est possible de
construire comme ça
cette voûte nubienne j'arrive donc à
boromo et la bôme avait me présente un
géant paysans série youlou il est parmi
nous ce soir et vous m'avez me dit
d'ailleurs tu vois ce type il est
suffisamment grand pour tenir les
briques de ton truc pendant que ça sèche
une complicité une amitié immédiate se
lit entre nous je lui explique le projet
lui-même connaît la terre le banco les
briques comme beaucoup de paysans
burkinabés et construit lui-même ses
proches sa propre maison et nous voilà
partis à la recherche de cette fameuse
voûte nubienne kèlè kèlè la
problématique qui sous tend notre moment
histoire c'est la problématique de
l'habitat pour le plus grand nombre
toutes les architectures traditionnelles
utilisait du bois en charpente charpente
plate couverte de terre ou charpente
pointu recouvertes de paille
déforestation et démographie se sont
conjugués pour interdire toutes ces
architectures traditionnelles et
aujourd'hui l'alternative moderne pour
la couverture des maisons pour l'immense
majorité des foyers africains c'est la
taule vous connaissez vous comprenez à
quel point cette tôle est inadaptée
inadaptés en termes de confort
la chaleur bien sûr mais aussi le froid
le bruit sous la pluie inadaptés en
termes d'économies sont les chevrons la
tôle sur des produits d'importation
inadaptés en termes de d'environnement
ce sont des produits avec une très forte
empreinte inadaptés en termes de
durabilité la tôle vieillit très mal et
puis ces bourrasques de vent de plus en
plus on rencontre de plus en plus qui
décoiffe
les maisons inadaptée aussi en termes de
culture imaginons nous vraiment que
l'afrique serait condamnée à ce que 80%
de la population vivent pendant des
générations uniquement sous la tôle
non bien sûr avant même d'avoir
construit quoi que ce soit avec série
s'impose à nous une idée c'est que
peut-être ce qu'on est en train de
rechercher deviendrait une alternative
crédible que l'on pourrait dire
fusé dans les campagnes au burkina ou
ailleurs et nous voilà partis pour
essayer de retrouver la voûte nubienne
trois semaines se passe
le symposium du pia mais se termine les
officiels sont là le préfet le haut
commissaire le directeur des eaux et
forêts et moi avec un aplomb dont je
m'étonne encore aujourd'hui je présente
un tas de briques cassées et a fièrement
que c'est l'avenir de l'architecturé
africaine
autant dire que je suis passer pour un
fou
on conseillera d'ailleurs à série de
s'éloigner de ce tube i'm qui était
peut-être contagieux mais on s'accroche
on continue et quelques semaines après
nous avons enfin notre première goutte
puis une deuxième
je reviendrai en 99 et à force de
travail on obtient un concept d'une
maison solide durable confortable
entièrement en matériaux locaux sans
tôle sans bois sans ciment nous sommes
imaginez le nous sommes pleins de l'idée
que c'est peut-être la nouvelle maison
africaine
mais la diffusion de ce concept continue
à nous nous en a nous envahir et se fait
une mission pour nous qui dit fusion dit
programme qui lie programme be un
opérateur pour le porter en 2000 secret
en france l'association la voûte
nubienne à pn qui devra permettre la
diffusion avoir une bonne idée est une
chose mais en matière de développement
prouver que cette bonne idée
on est effectivement une en vulgarisant
auprès du plus grand nombre
c'est tout à fait une autre paire de
manches on n'est pas dans la même
temporalité on n'est pas devant les
mêmes défis le marché s'impose tout de
suite à nos yeux comme étant le vecteur
de la diffusion de notre proposition le
marché va être en même temps le juge de
notre proposition parce que nous serons
capables d'avoir un marché est un marché
croissant et bien cela soulignera
l'intérêt de nos propositions et puis la
croissance du marché va devenir la
croissance de la vulgarisation ainsi à
vienne ne va pas vendre des maisons
vendre des voûtes nubiennes mais bien
permettre région après région
l'émergence et la croissance d'un marché
permettez-moi de paraphraser confucius
bien sûr il vaut mieux apprendre à
pêcher que donner du poisson mais il
faut sans doute aussi apprendre à
réparer le filet ou la canne à pêche et
apprendre à vendre du poisson on crée
ainsi une un cercle d'économie vertueuse
qui va pérenniser le développement de la
proposition nous faisions à l'époque
sans même connaître l'expression déjà de
l'entrepreneuriat social
s'ensuivent
quatre cinq six ans d'obstination
d'entêtement série et moi-même
sillonnons labrousse d'un village à
l'autre espérant là un nouveau client
ici un nouvel apprenti le scepticisme
est considérable quand il ne se mue pas
en adversité
on se rappelle sur ces chantiers de
voûte nubienne ou après des nuits de
très fortes pluies
on pouvait lire au très petit matin des
traces de vélo de ceux qui ayant prédit
la chute des bâtiments étaient venus
contrôler leurs prédictions mais les
voûtes est hélas bien solide
nous savons qu'il faudra des années des
décennies pour convaincre
nous savons aussi que plus les économies
sont fragiles plus la prise de risque
pour un produit nouveau et compliqué
nous savons aussi le poids que
représente la maison pour les familles
africaines mais nous sommes de moins en
moins seul des paysans des maçons
rejoignent le programme essence et
s'approprie le la technique en la
transmettant dans une dynamique de
formation sur le tas et dans un
processus de cooptation voilà un maçon
récemment acquis à la technique qui
propose aux chefs de son village lui
construit une voûte celui-ci ravi
accepte et se tourner vers les jeunes du
village pour qu'ils donnent un coup de
main cela refuse pas convaincu inquiète
la femme même du chef du village dit
qu'elle refusera de rentrer dans une
maison qui risque de lui tomber sur la
tête
le maçon relève le gant est dit très
bien on finira le bâtiment moi et mes
apprentis et c'est ce qu'ils font le
définissent cette voûte nubienne le
bâtiment devient une curiosité dans la
région des gens viennent de partout pour
le visiter le chef
très fier fait donc lui-même visiter son
bâtiment fini par s'y installer
sa femme finit aussi par les rejoindre
et pour boucler la boucle
elle refusera les visites dans sa
superbe maison le programme se dessine
un toit un métier un marché un toit ce
sont tous ces clients qui audacieux font
construire et toutes ces familles qui
vivent dans ces maisons confortables un
métier ce sont tous ces artisans leurs
apprentis qui utilisent ce nouveau fait
savoir faire pour diffuser la technique
et puis un marché c'est tous les
collaborateurs du programme qui avec ses
méthodologies de diffusion à grande
échelle met en relation ses clients
essais et ses maçons et les résultats
sont au rendez vous des chiffres c'est
sont aujourd'hui plus de 350 masson et
400 apprentis qui auront permis la
construction de plus de l'ouverture de
plus de 200 2500 chantier qui
appréhendent havrais 4000 voûte dans
près d'un millier de villes et villages
du de l'afrique de l'ouest se sont aussi
cette croissance on est à 30 % annuels
entre 20 et 30 % annuels de croissance
du marché tous les ans depuis dix ans et
puis toujours cette bonne étoile
cette volonté supérieure si je peux me
permettre qu'ils proposent soutien et
renforce le programme j'étais un jour
dans un village près d'un chantier à
cette superbe voûte qui avance comme ça
aérienne et puis il ya un homme assez
âgé sur un vélo qui est là qui regarde
qui regarde qui regarde il ya souvent
des gens qui regardent ces chantiers je
m'approche
de ce monsieur et salutations et puis je
dis qu'est ce que ça vous fait qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce que vous voyez le
gars me disent c'est quelque chose de
très important
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel mais en
même temps je vois qu'il est parti
contre et je lui demande pourquoi il me
dit voilà je suis j'ai fait 60 km en
vélo pour venir saluer des funérailles
on est en afrique et ce que je vois là
je peux pas retourner chez moi sans en
parler mais si je retourne chez moi et
que j'en parle on risque de nous traiter
de menteur et ça c'est pas possible je
suis donc obligé de partir chez moi ne
trouvaient deux camarades de revenir ici
et de repartir à nouveau pour qu'on
témoigner ensemble c'était 120 km de
plus en vélo ce jour là j'ai compris que
la voûte nubienne appartenait et
appartiendraient plus encore aux
africains cette aventure de
développement ses vingt ans d'engagement
pour les nombreux acteurs du programme
et nous sommes sans doute passer du
statut d'utopistes à celui de
visionnaire aujourd'hui où en sommes
nous aujourd'hui c'est le marketing des
artisans voûte nubienne qui est en
première ligne pour la diffusion
aujourd'hui c'est à vienne qui
accompagne accompagne des partenaires
issus de la société civile et du
développement pour leur transmettre des
méthodologies de diffusion qu'ils vont
développer sur leur propre territoire
et puis aujourd'hui c'est le plaidoyer
d'avesnes auprès des décideurs
politiques nationaux et internationaux
qui inscrit dans une conscience globale
l'essentialité de questions d'habitat
pour le plus grand nombre
et demain on a sans doute fait un bon
morceau du chemin mais l'objectif reste
devant nous l'objectif c'est la
diffusion à grande échelle d'une
architecture j'ose le mot je propose le
mot la diffusion à grande échelle d'une
architecture adaptée en afrique
cette histoire nourri d'ambitions de
complicité de passion m'a permis une vie
engagée et m'a vraiment enrichi ne parle
pas là d'argent et elle se poursuit en
prenant place dans les défis du siècle
dans les défis
du continent dans les défis de notre
humanité oui l'habitat du plus grand
nombre est un défi pour notre humanité
je voudrais partager avec vous une
dernière idée forte les problématiques
porte en elle les germes de leurs
solutions
les problématiques porte en elle les
germes de leur solution de leur
résolution vision collaboration
adaptation persévérance et le plaisir
devant les résultats obtenus sont les
outils du changement
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]